Speaker 1: There is a stunning new poll from
YouGov which finds that 66 percent of Americans,
I'm sorry, of Republicans in the southern
United States want to secede from the United
States and become their own country.
This was a joint poll between YouGov and Bright
Line Watch, and they did some interesting
things.
One of the things that the poll does is it
breaks down the country by regions.
So you've got like the Pacific region, which
is California, Washington, Oregon, Hawaii
and Alaska.
You've got all these, the Northeast, etc.
And what they did was they reported people's
interest in separating out as a country, not
at the state level, but as a region.
If your region could become its own country,
would you want to secede from the United States?
And they asked people this on the basis of
party affiliation.
So let's look at some examples here in the
northeast region as an example, which includes
Maine, New Hampshire, Vermont, New York, Pennsylvania,
Massachusetts, Connecticut, Rhode Island,
you know, a couple of Maryland, Delaware.
They said, OK, would you want to be your own
country and secede from the United States?
And for example, thirty nine percent of Democrats
said, yes, we do.
We would like to be our own region.
Thirty five percent of independents and only
twenty six percent of Republicans said I would
like the Northeast to be our own region.
The largest level of support in this poll
across all regions and political IDs is southern
Republicans.
If you look at the southern region that includes
Texas, Florida and a bunch of other states,
66 percent of Republicans said, yeah, I want
to secede.
I would like our region, the southern region,
to be its own country.
Now, the absolute most ironic thing about
this is that the southern region would be
completely unsustainable economically.
Some of.
The states that are the biggest takers rather
than givers when it comes to federal money
would be in that southern region, so set a
different way.
Some of the states that are the most dependent
on money that comes from other states through
the federal government are Mississippi, Kentucky,
South Carolina, Louisiana, Alabama, Tennessee,
Arkansas and Oklahoma.
They're all in what would be this southern
region of the United States.
Texas and Florida are kind of in the middle.
They're not terrible.
They're not great in terms of paying in versus
getting out.
So the point here is the group that most wants
to secede from the United States, Southern
Republicans, and make their own country out
of their region are the ones whose states
are the least economically able to do that
and the most dependent on blue states to subsidize
them.
This isn't new.
We've covered this.
We've done stories about this before, about
this contrast before.
It's been true for a very long time.
Now consider the reality versus perception.
Their perception is things are really bad
being part of the United States.
Why?
Because of Democrats and liberals and progressives
like Joe Biden's communism and his socialism
and the Marxist Democrats WOAK culture is
ruining us.
Cancel so-called culture is ruining us men
in girls sports as they love to say.
It's ruining the country.
And we'd be better off if we separated and
did our own thing.
That's the perception that many of them have.
The reality is none of that stuff is actually
going on.
There are almost no socialists in the Democratic
Party and however bad things are in your state
in terms of education and they're very bad
in a lot of these states.
However, bad things are in your state in terms
of access to health care infrastructure, it
would be even worse if you lost the subsidies
you get from blue states through the federal
government, blue states that are paying in
much more than they get out and making your
education system be slightly less terrible,
making your health care system be slightly
less terrible, making your infrastructure
slightly less terrible, it couldn't possibly
be more backwards.
And they have the idea these Southern Republicans,
if we separated and did our own thing, we
would be much better off.
But again, in a sense, just like I don't take
joy in the anti vaccine nurse that just died
of covid because I see her as a victim of
disinformation.
It's very similar for lots of these people
who wrongly blame their problems on imaginary
issues rather than the real failures of their
almost exclusively Republican state and local
level elected officials.
They are also the victims of disinformation.
They are persistently victims, by the way,
also.
Of a terrible education system in their states,
they can't even follow simple logic like,
oh, pandemic, OK, mask for now and then vaccine
once we can get it, they can't even follow
that.
So they are also victims to some degree.
Now, we'll have a voice mail about this with
a different perspective a little bit later
on.
Last thing on this, it shouldn't come as a
shock that the group that most glorifies the
side of the Confederacy during the Civil War
is the one that most wants to secede from
the union.
That's actually consistent.
That's not surprising.
And so it shouldn't come as a shock to us.
We're going to have more coverage of this
poll on our Instagram.
So make sure you're following us there at
David Pakman show.
We'll take a quick break and we will get to
the decidedly, overtly anti vax shift among
many prominent Republicans that took place
over this past weekend.